it's hard to come across an unfamiliar
face on the streets of stepanakert
nagona carback's largest city having
spent weeks here
it seems like everyone knows everyone
but half of the population has been
displaced
many have chosen to flee far less are
taking their chances in choosing to stay
it's been more than a week since the
first ceasefire was signed in moscow
and throughout this whole time the exit
has continued
the truce held only on paper this is one
of the worst scenes of destruction we've
witnessed in stepanaker
during the whole time that we've been
here basically a whole half of the house
has been demolished
by a huge bomb it didn't come from the
drone that's for sure because
drone strikes don't leave craters as big
as the one over there
here it seems used to be a small storage
unit or some storage facility
judging by a huge pile of firewood over
here
in stepanaket alone this is only one of
dozens of houses raised by the bombs of
truce
the destruction scales up across the
region every major town and many
villages have also been shelled
so when the second ceasefire was
announced locals here
took it almost like a mockery
there is no way the conflict can be
solved peacefully
armenians did live here so during these
30 years
they had to somehow resolve the conflict
what can i say about people who have no
idea of humanity
it is a pity that we are dealing with
barbarians and terrorists
i think that the ordinary azerbaijani
people the civilians
do not want war just like we don't want
it but if their leader wants their
people to die
let them die our boys will defend our
homeland
the fighting has long spilled beyond the
borders of nagorno-karabakh
the cease-fire didn't save azeri cities
from the shelling
too notably bombs rained down on the
civilian areas of azerbaijan's second
city of ganja
just like armenians azerbaijanis share a
religious belief that nagorno-karabakh
belongs to them
regardless of the cease-fire the
armenians continue to attack us
they shot civilians in mangachevir in
ganja countries around the world turn a
blind eye to these violations
powerful nations should not tolerate
this but they openly support them
both armies are ready to exterminate
each other if need be
and a diplomatic effort however large it
might be
can only do so much amigos dana
reporting from the gonna care
well control over nagorno-karabakh has
been contested for decades but
the dispute turned hot again at the end
of september
azerbaijani cities are also under
shelling despite
all the recent agreements local
journalist elmira moussozade brings us
the latest from the azeri region of
aghdam at midnight the next regime of
humanitarian truths
came into force however people in the
war zone tata
and akdam region do not relax last time
cease fire was broken
after half an hour shells launched by
armenian site hit residential houses
in sahlabad village in tata today
ceasefire was broken again starting on
the south
fiscally and jabra regions in the late
afternoon akdam came under fire
i am a soldier's mother when i heard the
news about the ceasefire
i called my relatives and complained
about this decision
we must go to the very end and liberate
all our lands
we fear nothing living near the front
line in akhdam
we believe in our soldiers and
presidents if they say they should be
peaceful resolution then we do not want
this war
we want our lands back no matter whether
it's at the negotiating table or
through war man
i was fighting against armenia in the
early 90s at that time armenians also
proclaimed ceasefires but never observed
them and occupied new territories when
we weren't expecting it
it's the same thing now they talk about
a ceasefire but shoot at civilians
we live in agdam the ceasefire didn't
even start there is no ceasefire
i haven't seen it
you